you ever gone to a really good street
fight
a really good street fight
you have i got into it yeah like a
really good one that you remember like i
mean i i've gotten to a street fight as
a professional athlete that's what i'm
saying yeah that part not in high school
like a professional athlete yeah i have
what was that like well i was i was
staying at this hotel in um in toronto
filming this movie and these guys came
back and they were being really loud and
they're like knocking on all the doors
as they're walking by
and i just got back from being you know
from shooting it was probably like
around 2 30. how would you in the
morning i'm like maybe maybe 30 years
old so peak yeah yeah yeah
bad bad time bad time
so i um i go i uh put my head out the
door and i do in my old man's voice i'm
like hey guys why don't you just
shuttle down you know just you got this
voice
he's got some good voices
did you kids get off my lawn
son of the [ __ ]
so
so i say that to him and then they
started getting lippy right so i'm just
like laughing and then i'm like all
right guys just just calm down so uh as
i stuck my out the window at the door
they started walking down
to how many guys by the way there's
three of them okay there's three guys
walk down to my door
and i'm still liking you know still like
in joking around mold but these guys are
kind of inebriated and they're kind of
like kind of pressing the action so i
have my door open and they're standing
right in front of my door and they're
threatening me they're gonna do things
to me and i said look if you cross into
my room
i'm gonna let you have it so i see one
of the guys like that's more of the
agitator than the rest of them the other
two were just kind of like backing him
up and then he walks forward and he
doesn't even get to my room i just
started feeding him and i started
hitting him mushrooms of course
yeah mushrooms
now to start hitting him and then i just
started hitting his buddies and then uh
the security guards came and you know i
didn't get kicked out of the hotel but
it was uh they didn't know who you were
or they knew who you were they didn't
know there was no way they knew who you
were that's what i'm saying how bad did
they get messed up i fed him pretty good
so if you can beat up three
20 year olds fed them at the same time
how many 10 year olds do you think
[Laughter]
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]